remember when Phil Harrison said
Microsoft had absolutely no plans at all
to release a Kinect free xbox one well
about that it turns out the company is
releasing a Kinect free xbox one this
June for four hundred dollars putting it
directly in line with the PlayStation 4
i'm mark Walton and this is a game spot
news update head of Xbox Phil Spencer
revealed the news of a Kinect free xbox
one on a post on Microsoft's Xbox news
channel revealing its 399 dollar price
tag and jun 9th release date we've heard
that you want more choices from xbox one
you want a wide variety of options in
your games and entertainment experiences
and you also want options in your
hardware selection the post reads to be
clear as we introduce this new Xbox one
console option connect remains an
important part of our vision if you buy
an xbox one for three hundred ninety
nine dollars and laters decide you want
to have all the experiences connect
enables we will also offer a standalone
sensor for Xbox one later this fall the
move follows a stream of backtracking on
Microsoft's original vision for the
console which included not being able to
use pre-owned games family sharing and
an always-on requirement to name but a
few as well as several strong denials
from the company that a kinect free xbox
one with being made favorites include
xbox one is connect they are not a
separate system we have absolutely no
plans to release Xbox one without
connect and a kinect free xbox one would
be a real shame as well as the kinect
for xbox microsoft also announced for
xbox gold subscribers will receive an
extra free game in June discounts on new
games for gold subscribers and that
media streaming apps like Netflix and
NBA gametime will no longer require an
xbox live gold subscription to use is
this a smart move from Microsoft are you
missed having had to fork out for a
connect with Xbox one and will you miss
all those fantastic connect based games
actually wait maybe not that last one
let us know in the comments below and
for more on this story keep your eyes on
gamespot
you